so Tim Einstein believes that the Baby
Einstein believes that the baby that the
baby Timothy is still there in in the
four-dimensional space time that the
older Timothy are all there we are all
Frozen pictures a long time I don't
believe this and you can't deny that
there is a huge discrepancy and a huge
[Music]
controversy there's the public
human perception of time and that's
where we get into all these paradoxes
because of the fact that we humans have
our own personal perception of time
which does not necessarily jive with the
physicist interpretation of time well
what's confusing is that the evolution
of time itself is confusing it starts
with Isaac Newton who said that time is
like an arrow so one second on the earth
is 1 second in Jupiter Einstein gives us
a river of time that speeds up and slows
down and perhaps even has whirlpools
which would correspond to perhaps black
holes comes the quantum theory and the
quantum theory that the river of time
can Fork Fork into many smaller rivers
and now we have something called String
Theory which is what I do for a living
and in string theory it explains not
just time but all the subatomic
particles has nothing but musical notes
on a tiny vibrating string and so time
now we realize is in some sense an
illusion it's an approximation it's an
average it's an average of all the
quantum possibilities so when you look
when you look at yourself in a mirror
you're not really seeing yourself as you
really are you're looking at a Quantum
average average over all possible
vibrations except now of course applied
to the universe we now get a Multiverse
of universes a bubble bath of universes
such that the Collision of two universes
gives you a big bang and that's why
we're here today so a time in that sense
is an illusion but if you look at the
Multiverse it all fits together H from
listening to Professor Kaku you may
believe that super string theory is now
established science that the Multiverse
is exists I don't think that there is a
Multiverse and I don't think that super
string theory is going to be the real
Theory but Einstein had a friend named
Mikela Bessel who was a he helped him
with a special and general theory of
relativity and he turned into philosophy
and Einstein was very mad at him uh but
then besso told him what I'm telling you
there is something about time that
relativity Theory ignores Einstein told
him you have to accept the fact that
subjective time with it with its
emphasis on the now is only an illusion
then a few years have passed sorry it
looked like a few years have passed
because didn't believe that time is
passing and something happened that
makes everybody realize that time is
passing Mikel besso son wrote to
Einstein and said my father passed away
Einstein had only four weeks to leave he
he he had an anism and he knew that he
was going to die he wrote to the son the
following letter Mikel has you remember
this letter Mikel has preceded me in
leaving this strange world this is not
important for us convinced physicists
the distinction between past present and
future is only an illusion however
persistent so Tim Einstein believes that
the baby ion believes that the baby that
the baby Timothy is still there in in
the four-dimensional space time that the
older Timothy are all there we are all
Frozen pictures a long time I don't
believe this and you can't deny that
there is a huge discrepancy and a huge
controversy just like it was between
these two great man I I just I need to
respond to everybody cites this letter
that Einstein wrote he wrote it three
three months before he himself died four
weeks okay even closer right at the end
of his life he wrote many popular
expositions of Relativity he wrote many
scientific expositions of Relativity he
never said that he was writing not a
scientific thesis he was writing a
letter of condolence to someone who just
lost someone and he said something very
can I please finish he he was not
claiming that nothing in his scientific
presentation or the use of general
relativity suggests anything like that
he was being nice and he wrote it in a
little private note that he wouldn't
even expect anyone else to read people
it's a very poetic note and I thank
Einstein for writing it but the
interpretation that this is a deep
Insight of physics he wasn't doing that
he was just trying to be nice when
people say that time in some sense is an
illusion I think we have to
differentiate between human time human
time which of course is what we measure
with our senses and absolute time the
time of the universe the absolute time
of the universe is quantum mechanical it
exists in a Multiverse of universes and
of course with relativity uh the whole
question of now is of course a relative
concept so we have to realize that we
are humans talking about the question of
now in a human term while as a physicist
we look at the absolute framework where
now is a relative concept and exists in
a Multiverse of universes so in other
words what I'm trying to say is our
human senses are an average we average
over the Multiverse otherwise we
couldn't survive we cannot survive in
hyperspace if all of a sudden we're hit
with all these four-dimensional Tigers
coming at us no we have to have an
average and that's why we can exist we
can exist in a four-dimensional quantum
mechanical world of the Multiverse
because we average over all these
phenomenon otherwise we go berserk can
can I just again and this actually
started when Professor Kaku said
Einstein said time is like an arrow he
doesn't say that but Einstein did
believe in absolute simultaneity let me
just explain this one thing Einstein
believed if I snap my
fingers that was an event and there is a
objective physical fact about what was
happening on the moon at that moment
what was happening on Alpha centur at
that moment what was happening as far
away as you like that's absolute
simultaneity it says that all of these
events there is a unique way to organize
them into these all happen then these
all happen then these all happen
Newton's very clear that he believes
that special in general relativity if
you take them at face value get rid of
that they just don't believe there's
such a thing that's absolutely correct
that has nothing to do with the flow or
time or direction of time and in special
in general relativity you replace that
with What's called the proper time we
there's a proper time where we are as we
sit here there's a proper time in all
the things in our minds and there are
there is a future and a past for this
event it has an absolute future an
absolute past all of those things still
exist getting rid of absolute
simultaneity is a tweak of not much
interest for everyday life it's an
interesting theoretical thing to do I
actually think you have to put it back
in but that's another story um but to to
you don't want to whatever you want to
do you want to separate the question is
there absolute simultaneity to is there
a difference between past and future
does time do things change again it
sounds a little strange to say the
entire universe is made up of vibrating
strings but there's no time because to
vibrate time has to be going on right
vibration is a motion so it it seems a
little odd to say at B Bas there are
things that are vibrating but after all
time isn't at the base those those ideas
don't
SH now Tim I'm talking special
relativity and you know this Paradox the
Paradox of the BN and the pole or here
is as I put it you have a tunnel in
space one 100 m long you have a
spacecraft 100 m long and then the
spacecraft moves close to the speed of
light it becomes contracted right so
much so that the operator of the tunnel
can close the two doors at the same time
such that the the the spacecraft in
betweenin them now you sit on the
spacecraft and you say I'm at I'm at
rest and it's the tunnel which moves
relatively to me and now it it's the
tunnel which contracts the tunnel cannot
close its two doors at the same time you
know this Paradox you probably teach it
at class and I explain why it's not a
paradox yeah and you and then here is
your solution there is no absolute
simultaneity so one of them says I close
the two doors at at the same time and
open them the other said you lie to me
you close this one and open and close
this one and open that means Tim that
the two events coexist a long time the
whole Lauren contraction oh yes the
whole Lauren contraction is just by
minkovsky genius idea treating time as a
dimension you wouldn't get the Lawrence
contraction you wouldn't get time
dilation if you did not treat space and
time as a four-dimensional
Unity now to say that time is moving let
me be the Devil's Advocate because this
is what they say if you say that there
is a now that moves moving means being
in one place at one time at another
place at another time what is the
velocity of of of the now moving this is
why people say don't say the time move
you are mixing categories by the way it
was not only in the letter of condolence
first of all never write such a letter
of condolence to anybody who dear one
passed away but einan said it to the
philosopher Rudolf kup and he said we
the fact that we have to give up the
progression of the now is a matter of
painful but inevitable resignation here
is a talk between two philosophers you
can read his book The volume Einstein
physicist philosopher you will see in
his answer at the end against poer that
he said yeah I don't believe that there
is such a thing as the motion of time
the problem Tim the
discrepancy exists the debate exists
let's not ignore it yeah I would have to
emphasize that we're really debating two
separate though related questions on one
hand we have the physicist attitude
towards special relativity this is well
established all the paradoxes were
pretty much ironed out decades ago but
as far as Einstein's special Theory
relativity is I teach that and it's
settled it's a settled question like I
said before that's why we have hydrogen
BS there's no debate about what happens
when you pull the trigger on a nuclear
weapon once again to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit I a.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest
ideas